This research program is about
building AIs,
and developing AIs
in places that big companies
aren't going to do it
and academic researchers
were focused on it, but there was a whole
missing middle of exciting opportunities and
applications that would help a lot of people
that weren't being developed.
And so the impetus for this proposal was to
put that together.
Basically in all of these big social
problems
whether it's education,
or health, or climate
where the problem is predicated
on uncertainty
and AIs that are
basically prediction tools
can reduce the uncertainty
and benefit society
there's very few times in a person's lifetime
where they have a chance to work on a problem
that can have such a big social impact.
This is one of those times.
CIFAR has a unique funding model through this
program that enables us to do 2 things, 1
is to work on a really hard problem over a
long period of time, so a lot of grant funding
programs are much shorter.
This one gives a very long runway, and it
enables multi-disciplinary.
So the team we've put together where we have
domain expertise for example in public health
and medicine along with computer science expertise
particularly machine learning and AI, economics
expertise and psychology is a distinct group
that without CIFAR's patient model to deal
with complex research questions we will measure
whether this project is successful by the
lives it impacts through helping control or
reduce the impact of climate change by - through
health and through education.
[Music]